they build homes which they could never
afford to live in work has restarted at
this construction site and other pradesh
but many of the migrant laborers have
decided to leave because they haven't
been paid in months they're waiting for
special trains organized by the
government to transport workers to their
home states the district magistrate came
and took all of our names and told us
we'll get a message on our phones about
the trains
we've been waiting but we haven't got
anything and we have no means to leave
there are around 700 laborers from all
over India who've been living in turn
shacks next to the construction site the
only food many of them get is from a
wealthy benefactor who's spending around
$200 of his own money every day to feed
1,300 laborers in the area five of my
friends and I check every day how much
food people need and we feed them we
aren't sponsored by any political party
or NGO it's my own resolve that I'm
carrying out some workers have decided
to walk home instead of depending on the
kindness of strangers for food or the
government to transport them the work
has restarted but who will look after
the children at home we have to think of
our children too and not just work who's
feeding them here we worry about our
children we won't be scared at home
Kalavati plans to walk 600 kilometres
with her friend and children to their
home state of Madhya Pradesh since the
lockdown began on the 25th of March an
estimated 10 million labourers have been
stranded in cities or states which
they're not from with no work or income
and a long way from home
with all public transport canceled over
half a million walked home often
hundreds of kilometers after protests by
migrant workers the government agreed to
organize train services home last week
but government leaders are under
pressure from industries is very open
with company managers fearing they won't
have enough workers the state of
Karnataka cancelled the trains just a
few days after they began saying migrant
workers needed to stay to do their part
and reviving the economy the
cancellation follows a meeting between
the state's leader and the real estate
developers Association of India I think
it's an extraordinary act of ingratitude
because we essentially believe that the
migrant workers that have been abandoned
in this case are the very individuals
who will build our own future prosperity
Mahesh Sharma says that the economic
impact of India's Mactan will be felt
for a long time because of its
humanitarian failure with migrants less
willing to return to the cities
Elisabeth puranam al Jazeera Greater
Noida orthopod a sh